hey everyone bandit here real quick i
just wanted to give you a warning
because the nintendo direct is in less
than two hours from now um do not go on
twitter okay i even put this warning in
the thumbnail just in case people didn't
click on this video because this is the
only way that i knew how to get this
word out there are actual spoilers and
leaks for the nintendo direct that are
legitimately real floating around on
twitter and possibly other news sources
i've seen them so uh unfortunately i've
already been spoiled for a couple things
so uh take my word for it uh you don't
want to see them if you don't want to be
spoiled for the direct anyway this is
the only way that i knew how to get the
word out uh as quick as possible
short little video that's really all
i've got um i'll see you guys in a
couple hours because i'll be uploading
reactions and stuff anyway thank you
guys don't go on twitter unless you
don't care about spoilers then you can
go on twitter but other than that don't
go on twitter alright peace